welcome to the presentation on finding
sums of integers you're probably
wondering why are we doing this within
the context of averages and well if you
think about it all an average is is you
take a sum of a bunch of numbers and
then you divide by the numbers the
number of numbers you have and what
we're gonna do here is do a couple
algebra problems that involve just the
sum parts first and actually they can
carry over into I guess average problems
as well let's get started with a problem
let's say I told you that I had the sum
let's see the sum of five consecutive
integers consecutive like if integers is
equal to 200 what is the smallest I
apologize for my handwriting what is the
smallest of the five integers well
there's a couple of ways to do this and
but I guess the the most straightforward
way is just to do it algebraically I
would say so let's say that X is the
smallest of the integers right so X is
actually what we're gonna want to figure
out smallest of integers well if X is a
smallest what are the other four going
to be right we have a total of five well
they're consecutive consecutive just
means that they follow each other like
five six seven eight nine ten and all of
those are consecutive integers right and
if you remember integers are just whole
numbers so it can't be a fraction or a
decimal so if X is the smallest so then
the next integer is going to be X plus
one and then the one after that's going
to be X plus two and the one after
that's going to be X plus three and the
one after that's going to be X plus four
right and it might seem confusing I'm
writing all these X's but if you think
about it if X was 5 then this would be 6
this would be 7 this would be 8 and this
would be 9 and that's all I'm writing
here right so these would be assuming
that X is a smallest of the integers the
5 integers would be X X plus 1 X plus 2
X
3 + x + 4 and we know that the sum of
these 5 consecutive integers is 200 well
what can what is the sum of these 5 I
guess we could say numbers or
expressions well let's see we have 5 X's
1 2 3 4 5 so X plus X plus X plus X plus
X is equal to just 5 X right or you can
just say 5 times X and then that's plus
1 plus 2 is 3 3 plus 3 is 6 6 plus 4 is
10 so the sum of these five integers is
going to be 5x + 10 and all I did is add
up the X's and then added up the
constants and we know that that is going
to equal 200 and now this is just a
level two linear equation we could just
solve for X so we get 5x is equal to 109
I just subtracted 10 from both sides
right and then X is equal to let me
divide 5 into 195 goes into let's see 5
goes into 19 3 times 3 times 5 is 15 9
minus 5 is 4 bring down the 0 5 goes
into 48 times so X is equal to 38 pretty
straightforward problem when you think
now what if I were to ask you what is
the average of the five consecutive
numbers well now there's two ways of
doing this now that we already know that
X is 38 we know that the other numbers
are gonna be well this is 38 39 40 41 42
well we could just average these four
numbers you just say 38 + 39 + 40 + 41 +
42 and well we already know what those I
don't you have to do the math we already
know that they average up - they sum up
to 200 and then we divide the sum by
five because there are five numbers so
the average is 40 Ford enough 46 the
average is 40 and there's a couple of
ways you could think about that one you
see 40 just the middle number so that
makes sense
and it's and the only time we can really
say it's the middle number is when the
numbers are distributed evenly around 40
right if we had a number that was
smaller than 40 or something you
couldn't just necessarily pick the
middle number but in this case it's
they're consecutive and makes sense
another way we could have done this
problem if you were say taking the SAT
and they were to ask you well you know
the sum of five numbers is 200 what's
the average of the numbers well you say
well I just have to do is divide that
200 by five and I'll get 40 let's do
another problem I'll make it a little
bit harder let's say the sum of let's
say 7 odd numbers the sum of 7 odd
numbers let me make up a good I hope
this one works I'm gonna try to do it in
my head is 217 what is the largest
number
I shouldn't say number 7 odd integers
actually becomes a much harder problem
if it was just 7 odd no actually the
only thing that could be odd are
integers anyway so you can almost assume
it but the sum of 7 odd integers is 217
what is the largest of the integers as
you can tell I'm doing this on the fly
and actually my wife just diagnosed me
with she thinks I have benign vertigo I
got very dizzy this morning when I went
to work so you have to forgive me for
that as well that that's that's
impairing me even more close to this
problem let's say that X is the largest
then what would the number right below x
be would it be X minus 1 well if X is an
odd number X minus 1 would be an even
number so if we say that if we say that
so in order to get the number right
below we have to do X minus 2 to get
another odd number Oh in my apologies it
should say the sum of 7 consecutive odd
if you assume that I'm trying my best
today to confuse you so the sum of seven
consecutive odd integers is 217 what is
the largest of the integers so if X is
the largest then the next smallest one
would be X minus 2 right because it's
consecutive odd numbers not just
consecutive right so consecutive odd
numbers are like 1 3 5 7 you're skipping
the evens right so that's why you're
going up or down by 2 depending how you
view it so the next one down would be X
minus 2 then we'll have X minus 4 X
minus 6 X minus 8 X minus 10 X minus 12
I think that's it 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 right
those are 7 numbers they're separated by
2 X is the largest of them right and we
can assume that they're awed because
apparently the problem will work out so
that they're on so what is the sum of
these 7 numbers well the 7 X is just add
up to 7 X and then let's see let's see 2
+ 4 is 6 6 6 is 12 12 + 8 is 20 20 + 10
is 30 30 + 12 is 32 so 7 X - 32 is equal
to 217 and we just solve for X 7 X is
equal to see if we add 32 to both sides
of this equation we get 249 let's see 7
goes into 249 is that right it's 200
right so 7 goes into 249 could I do this
addition properly I want to make sure 2
plus 4 is 6 6 plus 6 is 12 12 plus 8 is
20 20 plus 10 is 30 30 plus 12 is 42 oh
here we go see my mathematical spider
sense could tell that something was was
fishy about this so that 7x minus 42 and
that's so if we had 42 to both sides
that 7x is equal to 259
see how brave I am I do this thing in
real time 259 so 7 goes into 259 G 7
goes into 25 3 times 3 times 7 is 21 49
goes into 30 seven times so we get X is
equal to 37 and we're done
so just to review cuz I think I I kind
of got a lot of errors in this problem
when I presented it the question was the
sum of 7 consecutive odd integers is 217
what is the largest of the integers I
said X is the largest and then if X is
the largest the next smaller one will be
X minus 2 because we're not saying just
consecutive integers we're saying
consecutive odd integers right so if X
is 37 which is what we solved for then X
minus 2 is 35 this is 33 this is 31 this
is 29 this is 27 this is 25 and then we
just added up all the X's and then salt
and then and all added up all the
constants and said that well they add up
to 217 and then we just solved for X I
think you're now ready to try some of
these problems have fun